so
acknowledging that there's a separate
person and accepting
you for who you are uh now
on a slightly that and you mentioned
therapeutic that sounds very like a very
healthy view of love
but uh is there also like uh
like you know if we look at heartbreak
and uh you know most love songs are
probably about heartbreak right
is that like the mystery the tension the
danger
the fear of loss
you know all of that what people might
see in a negative light as like games
or whatever but just
just the the dance of human interaction
yeah fear of loss and fear of like
you said like once you feel it once you
long for it again
but you also once you feel it once you
might for many people
they've lost it so they fear losing it
they feel lost
so is that part of it like you're
speaking like beautifully about like the
positive things but
is it important to be able to uh be
afraid of losing it
from an engineering perspective
i mean it's a huge part of it and
unfortunately we all
you know um face it at some points in
our lives i mean
i did you want to go into details how
did you get your heart broken
sure well so mine is pretty straight my
source pretty straightforward
um there
i did have a friend that was you know
that at some point um
in my 20s became really really close to
me and we we became really close friends
um i grew up pretty lonely so in many
ways when i'm building
you know this these ai friends i think
about myself when i was 17 writing
horrible poetry and you know in my
dial-up modem at home and
um you know and that was the feeling
that i grew up with i left
i lived um alone for a long time when i
was a teenager
where did you grow up in moscow in the
outskirts of moscow
um so i just skateboard during the day
and come back home and you know
connect to the internet and write
pokemon and then write horrible poetry
and was it love poems
all sorts of fun obviously love poems i
mean what what other poetry can you
write when you're 17.
it could be political or something but
yeah but that was
you know that was kind of my yeah like
deeply um
influenced by joseph brodsky and like
all sorts of sports that
um every 17 year old will
will be looking you know looking at and
reading
but yeah that was my uh these were my
teenage years and
i just never had a person that i thought
would you know
take me as it is would accept me the way
i am
um and i just thought you know working
and just doing my thing
and being angry at the world and being a
reporter i was an investigative reporter
working undercover and
writing about people was my way to
connect with
you know with with others i was deeply
curious about
every everyone else and i thought that
you know if
i go out there if i write their stories
that means i'm more connected
this is what this podcast is about by
the way i'm desperately alone seeking
connection
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding or am i i don't know so
what wait
a reporter uh what
how did that make you feel more
connected i mean you're
still fundamentally pretty alone but
you're always with other people you know
you're always thinking about what other
place going to infiltrate what other
community can i write about what other
phenomena can i explore and he's sort of
like a trickster you know and
like and a mythological character like
creature that's just jumping
uh between all sorts of different worlds
and feel and feel sort of okay with
in all of them so um that was my dream
job by the way that was like
totally what i would have been doing um
if russia was a different place and a
little bit undercover
so like you weren't you were trying to
like you said mythological creature
trying to infiltrate
so try to be a part of the world what
are we talking about what kind of things
did you enjoy writing about i'd go work
at a strip club
or go
awesome okay uh well i'd go work at a
restaurant
or just go write about you know um
certain phenomenons or phenomenons of
people in in the city
and what uh sorry to keep interrupting
i'm the worst
i'm a conversationalist what
stage of russia is this what uh is this
pre-putin
post-putin what was russia like
pre-putin is really long ago
uh this is putin error that's uh
beginning of 2000's
and 2010 2007 8 9 10.
what were strip clubs like in russia in
restaurants
and culture and people's minds like in
that early russia that you were covering
in those early 2000s was there was still
a lot of hope there was still tons of
hope that
um you know we're
sort of becoming this uh western
westernized society
uh the restaurants were opening we were
really looking and you know
um we're trying we're trying to copy a
lot of things from
uh from the us from europe uh bringing
all these things in very enthusiastic
about that
there was a lot of you know stuff going
on there was a lot of hope and
dream for this you know new moscow that
would be
similar to i guess new york i mean just
to give you an idea in
um year 2000 was the year one
we had two uh movie theaters in moscow
and there was this one first coffee
house that opened
and it was like really big deal uh by
2010 there were all sorts of things
everywhere
almost like a chain like a starbucks
type of coffee house or like you mean
oh yeah like a starbucks i mean i
remember we were reporting on like we
were writing about the opening of
starbucks i think in 2007 that was one
of the biggest things that happened in
you know in moscow back back in the time
like that was worthy of a magazine cover
and uh that was definitely the you know
the biggest talk of the time
yeah when was mcdonald's because i was
still in russia when mcdonald's opened
that was in the 90s i mean yeah i
remember that very well
yeah those were long long lines i think
it was 1990
three or four i don't remember um
earlier mcdonald's at that time did you
do that i mean that was a luxurious
salting that was definitely not
something you do every day and also the
line was at least three hours
so if you're going to mcdonald's that is
not fast food that is like at least
three hours in line
yeah and then no one is trying to eat
fast after that everyone is like trying
to enjoy as much as possible
what's your memory of that oh it was
insane extremely positive
it's a small strawberry milkshake and a
hamburger and small fries and my mom's
there and
sometimes i'll just because i was really
little they'll just let me run you know
up the cashier and like
cut the line which is like you cannot
really do that in russia or
so like for a lot of people like a lot
of those experiences might seem
not very fulfilling you know like it's
on the verge of poverty i suppose but
do you remember all that time fondly
like
because i do like the first time i drank
you know coke
you know all that stuff right um
and just yeah the connection with other
human beings in russia
i remember i remember really positively
like how do you remember what the 90s
and then the rush you were covering
just the human connections you had with
people
and the experiences well my
my parents were both both physicists my
grandparents were both
well my grandpa grandfather was an
um nuclear physicist a professor at the
university
my dad worked at chernobyl when i was
born in chernobyl
analyzing kind of the everything after
the explosion
and then i remember that and they were
so they were making
sort of enough money in the soviet union
so they were not you know
extremely poor or anything it was pretty
prestigious to be a professor
uh the dean and the university and i
remember my grandfather started making a
hundred dollars a month
after you know in the 90s so then i
remember we started
our main line of work would be to go to
our
little tiny country house uh get a lot
of
apples there from apple trees bring them
back to
to um to the city and sell them in the
street
so me and my nuclear physicist
grandfather were just standing there and
he
selling those apples the whole day
because that would make you more money
than
you know working at the university and
then he'll just tell me try to teach me
um you know something about planets
and whatever the particles and stuff and
you know i'm not smart at all so i could
never understand anything but
i was interested as a you know
journalist kind of type interested
but that was my memory and you know i'm
happy that i wasn't um
i somehow got spared that i was
probably too young to remember any of
the traumatic stuff so
the only thing i really remember had
this bootleg that was very traumatic
i had this bootleg nintendo which was
called dandy in russia
so in 1993 there was nothing to eat like
even if you had any money you would go
to the store and there was no food i
don't know if you remember that
and our friend had a um restaurant like
a
government half government owned
something restaurant
so they always had um supplies so he
exchanged a big bag of weed
for this nintendo that looked like
nintendo
and then i remember very fondly because
i think it was nine
or something like that and or seven
traumatic because we just got it and i
was playing it and there was this you
know dandy tv
show yeah um so dramatically positive
sense you mean like
like a definitive well they took it away
and gave me a bag of wheat instead and i
cried like my
eyes out for oh i thought the other day
days and days oh no
and then you know as a and my dad said
we're gonna like exchange it back in a
little bit so you keep the little
gun you know the one that you shoot the
ducks with so i'm like okay i'm keeping
the gun so sometimes it's going to come
back
but then they exchanged the gun as well
for some sugar or something
i was so pissed i was like i didn't want
to eat for days after that i'm like i
don't want your food keeping my nintendo
you